Halloween is just around the corner and
you know what that means being socially
bullied into attending a fancy dress
party full of people you've never met
and you know what everyone else is gonna
dress up as zombie sexy zombie vampire
sexy vamp Jason Voorhees sexy Jason
Voorhees so why not do something
completely different
why not dress up like a video game
character that nobody else at the party
will recognize I mean if we're gonna go
through the sickening process of making
small talk with somebody ironically
dressed as Bill Cosby you might as well
look like a total prick while doing it
take it from me a loser who dress up
like a half like two zombie back in 2008
hell yeah went home alone at the end of
that night you'd be surprised how warm
soft inviting that mask was by the time
I stumbled into my bedroom before eh oh
yeah anyway here my top dope-ass picks
for Halloween costumes for gamers in
2015 you're welcome number 5 Gary from
vault 108 the vault dweller is a popular
gamer Halloween costume for a number of
reasons number one it's comfortable
you're basically wearing a [ __ ]
onesie for them number two it's cheap
again you're basically wearing one piece
of clothes number three every time you
slam a bottle of beer you're actually
making money I can do you one better
than just a generic vault waiter who's
expected to be able to talk and
socialise and generally be normal you
can be Gary from vault 108 Gary you see
Gary and fault 108 was a product of a
cloning experiment gone wrong so there
are dozens of him and he's only able to
say one word his name Gary so anytime
anyone talks to you at the party
just be like Gary okay here let's
practice oh hi what's your name Gary
that's a nice shade of blue what are you
dressed as Gary
hmm oh okay what's Gary from Gary oh
I've never watched Gary
okay nice to meet you and see you ran
the party Gary Gary Gary okay see you
later Harry
Gary number four EA cover athlete so
who's your favorite ea sports superstar
do you want Fame like Patrick Kane are
you DTF for ODB you want to slam some
shots down as Alex more guys whoever it
is EA supplies one of the simplest video
game Halloween costumes every single
gear you probably already own shorts
socks and a jersey right make sure you
stick on some feets and you're good
go now I know what you're thinking but
daddy I'm just dressing up like a sports
star
this isn't video games so here's the
kicker just buy yourself a pack of cards
and spend the entire night trying to
sell them to everyone else at the party
for five dollars perfect you're now an
EA game Peter more would be primed
number three choirs say what you want to
bet Hideo Kojima's sophomoric depiction
of women in Metal Gear Solid five but he
supplied gamers at one of the most
cost-effective Halloween costumes of all
time most of the [ __ ] you need to look
like quiet you probably already own like
bra tights a pair of gloves if you don't
have combat boots you cost you about
twenty dollars on Amazon then just duct
tape your left arm do a real shitty
mascara job and you're good to go and
here's the best part
quiet doesn't speak so you don't even
have to talk to any of the creepy
weirdos at the party just sitting in the
corner humming to yourself and slamming
Jager bombs or better yes to be
completely safe watch the party unfold
from a tactical vantage point half a
kilometer away in fact if you live close
enough to the party you can just stay at
home and play the final game instead
number two Johnny from The Witcher 3 The
Witcher 3 has some great costumes but
most of them involve 11 of investment
that's getting into hardcore larper
territory Halloween is all about
throwing together some [ __ ] at the last
minute why Johnny from The Witcher 3
Wild Hunt is perfect for those who just
want to show off the low of Sidi
projects world without having to press
Amazon for codpieces
just throw a red scarf around your neck
use a rag as a pair of fans hate
yourself blue and you're done
Plus Donnie doesn't talk for most of the
games he could just use the quiet trick
here and not bother speaking to anyone
or just put on an over-the-top English
accent whenever anyone asks you any
questions is talking about how you'd
like to take shits at sunrise soon as I
woke I went to empty my bowels in favor
number one Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 5 ok
bear with me on this one dressing up as
a skateboarder easy right stick on some
DC's a fine shirt and take a loan of
your friends deck done the trick is
making sure people know you're actually
dressed up as the game so here's what
you do first of all it's important that
you were super boring just tedious as
all hell talk to people but don't really
look at them in the eyes or ask them any
questions just talk about how you're
feeling and never finish a sentence just
trail off and then stare at their feet
be boring ok got it
next you're gonna want to fall over
unrealistically a pretty steady
intervals find something in the
environment say like a chair or table or
another guest walk into it and just
collapse lose all control of your body
remain lifeless on the ground for like
two or three seconds maybe try and fall
through the environment to fish and then
stand up as if nothing happened walk
away and then do it again a couple of
minutes later ok lastly and this is key
you're gonna want to leave the party and
a visit another one at least every few
minutes Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 5 is a
game where you're constantly dropping in
and out of online lobbies for no
discernible reason so make sure you RSVP
to at least half a dozen parties in the
same part of town spend time at one
party and then without caution just run
at the door and into the next part you
just keep rotating every few minutes the
moment it seems like you're feeling
comfortable in one place just booked it
at the door and go to the next one make
sure it constantly interrupts the flow
of your evening oh and make sure you ask
everyone at the party to give you sixty
dollars even though you're a tedious
flake who looks like [ __ ] and
disconnects every few minutes and that's
the top 5 Halloween costumes for gamers
in 2015 if you have any suggestions of
your own please put them in the comment
box below or tweet me at Danny O'Dwyer
see you next year's spooky gamers
you